it's hard to have a fresh start when the  past is on your mind I think we have  some unfinished business to talk about  [Music]  but it's a new me  [Music]  we'll Bettelheim your credit came back  sparkling well I looked you up you're  not on the socials that you might be  some kind of freak and I'm told  la is what you make it  who you surround yourself with  hello you love it's nice to meet you  love maybe I should run but I don't want  to what are your intentions with my  sister  perfect bye perfect  [Music]  what do you want Candace you did it  again didn't you  this is about your ex's name  she really hurt you  [Music]  if he loves you that's the most  dangerous thing  [Music]  [Applause]  I won't let this situation go bad  nothing is okay without you love  be whatever you want you're so very  special I wish I was special  [Music]  you